of all the iconic stories to emerge from
the League of Legends World
Championships a few are as memorable as
the Taipei Assassins run in 2012 the
Taiwanese outfit became overnight
sensations not only for their incredible
play but for decisively overcoming
arguably the three strongest teams at
the tournament in a series of
history-making upsets this is when
assassins ruled the world
heading into
the 2012 World Championship everyone's
eyes were fixed on a pair of teams to
win it all there was Moscow 5 the CIS
juggernaut who had dominated the scene
thanks to their innovation and
aggression and Korea's Azubu Frost a
team whose fearsome reputation caused
opposing teams and their fans across the
world to quake in their boots this
fanfare was not the case for the Taipei
Assassins in fact they were a massive
question mark heading into the
tournament a total dark horse they're
all but non-existent experienced against
international competition caused many to
view them with uncertainty and although
they had utterly dominated their home
region thanks to strong team
coordination and creative play it was
unknown how that would translate against
the world's best on league's biggest
stage but as we all know assassins work
best with the element of surprise as
champions of their region the Taipei
Assassins were seeded  directly into the
playoff bracket and their first opponent
wasn't going to be an easy one
they were slated to face Korea's second
representative the intimidating
NaJin Sword
who had steamrolled their group while
TPA were coming in cold
Lead by Lau "Toyz" Wai Kin and his now legendary Orianna
game 1 was a statement of intent proving
that the Taipei Assassins
going to back down against anybody
(Casting)
Game 2 started with NaJin in the lead
but the Assassins crawled its way back into it with some ferocious team fighting
(Casting)
By it's end the Taipei Assassins superior map
control team fight execution and coordination
Overwhelmed their Korean adversary
(Casting)
the sweep over NaJin
caught the world's attention the Taipei
Assassins passionate celebrations and
infectious energy captivated viewers
just as much as their unexpectedly high
level of play
"we said earlier you can only be as good as the competition you're playing against"
"TPA kind of proved us wrong there"
"TPA proved to everybody that we are not only the king"
"of South-East Asia, and we will play even better"
while the win brought cautious optimism to
their new fans there was still much work
to be done why because Taipei Assassins
next opponent was going to be an even
bigger test the love or hate them
Moscow 5 taking down a tournament
favorite like Moscow 5 would be no
easy task and after getting torn apart
in the first game of the series
the obvious question was weather or not
TPA were up to the challenge
(Casting)
but that question was answered
definitively in game two
can lock them down with the turrets damn
that gets out of that and it's just huge
pressure from Taipei Assassins right now
Darien is however able to clean up a few
kills for his team it's now three two
three four two three now finally the
last Auto Attack and double kill for
"toyz" aces on the Moscow 5 they're gonna
gain some huge ground here as they turn
Moscow 5 face in to shambles
Moscow 5 not exactly flustered but I
think this is the first time we have
seen them not be able to answer a
strategy "toyz" just back down to his team
and it's gonna be that second at first
Nexus turret the second Nexus turret the
Nexus now a game three Moscow 5
forced to defend on the fountain and
it's going to be a huge matchup your
first semifinal match going into a best of three Taipei and Moscow 5
in a deciding third game the Taipei Assassins
continued their onslaught by mixing up
their strategy, focusing on objective
control instead of teamfights and by the
20-minute mark they had a 5 to 0 tower
lead over Moscow 5
"and I'm surprised
actually they played it as a split push it's working out"
emboldened by their sizable gold lead the
Assassins went for Moscow fives jugular
out he can't even alter the crescendo
stopping them from using the abilities
diamondprox goes downs inhibitor is open
the double kill comes out Moscow 5
looking very grim right now Taipei
Assassins look to take down the last
nexus turret and they will drop Moscow 5
from the League of Legends Championship
playoffs and would you look at that the
cheers the yells at the look of relief
all makes at the same time on their
faces Taipei Assassins are the first team
to make it to the world finals
after two
dramatic upsets that Taipei Assassins
had made it to the finals only to have
to face the final boss Azubu Frost who
had been living up to their terrifying
reputation
a push lane instead of a stone comes
illusion from behind the dust bringers
(Casting)
it was going to be a slugfest of the dark horse that had
toppled two Titans enroute to the finals
against the expected champions but the
Taipei Assassins did not care for
expectations
armed with steadfast self-belief and
backed by a legion of ravenous
supporters they charged into the game
(Casting)
however Azubu Frost would begin to turn
things around off the back of a
now-famous Quadra kill by rapid star on
Karthus
(Casting)
eventually the Koreans would seal game
despite giving up the lead in the series the Taipei Assassins
would bounce back in game 2
thanks to Sung "Lilballz" Kuan-Po's
jungle Dr. Mundo which caught as Azubu Frost completely off-guard
(Casting)
in Game three "Toyz" Orianna would make a triumphant return
"they know the game was over Azubu Frost they just wanted to get on to the next game that could be a"
"smart call they knew that lingering in
that game was only going to demoralize"
"them so they decided to end it early"
the Taipei Assassins were one went away from
the unlikeliest of world titles and in
game four they showed Azubu Frost no mercy
(Casting)
with total map control and a 17 K gold lead the Taipei Assassins went for the killing blow
they had done it the Taipei Assassins
had an emphatically taken down three of the
world's best teams to become world
champions
"they took down the cream of the crop NaJin Sword looked unstoppable out of group stage Moscow 5 was the"
"favorites coming into the tournament
lose the first one against the"
"champions of Korea and then take three
games in a row"
the Taipei Assassins run has become something of a legend it comes from a time when league of legends
was still growing and theirs was easily
one of the most exciting storylines to
grace the game up to that point sure
looking back on the games now we can see
how far the competitive scene has come
the macro decisions team fighting and
execution are far more developed today
but the Taipei Assassins story at Worlds
2012 still embodies the amazing spirit
of league's early days
the passion
the fun
the triumphant underdog how can you
not love that